okay this is gonna be a complicated
story I'm gonna do the best I can to
explain this to you but we have yet
another corroboration of the fact that
this plan to remove sanctions from
Russia was something that Trump's
attorney Michael Cohen worked on and
that it did make its way to the White
House and to disgrace National Security
Advisor Michael Flynn we've learned now
that a Russia friendly Ukrainian
lawmaker has gone rogue and participated
in passing along these peace proposals
to Trump's inner circle I'm talking
about Andrei our dameng Co who's a
conservative pro-russian member of the
Ukrainian Parliament and he used to be a
part of Ukraine's far-right radical
party late last month he met in New York
with Trump's personal lawyer Michael
Cohen and Russian American advisor to
the Trump Organization Felix Sater who
has in the past been convicted of felony
fraud and stabbing a man in the face the
three of them talked about artemon COEs
plan for resolving the conflict between
Ukraine and Russia this is the plan that
surrounded Michael Flynn's resignation
which was reportedly hand-delivered by
Michael Cohen Trump's personal attorney
this is the plan which included the
lifting of American sanctions against
Russia which would also allow Russia to
seize the Crimean Peninsula or
effectively not have to give it back and
in return Russia would stop supporting
the separatists the plan also included
some revealing information about
ukrainian President Petro poroshenko
that would have forced him to resign it
would be an all-around win for Russia
and this there's a number of different
scandals here scandal one is that the
Ukrainian government has said that
actually our tamango had no authority to
negotiate peace talks with foreign
governments and he's now being
investigated for treason
but the real us-centric scandal is that
again it is more corroboration that
indeed Michael Cohen Trump's lawyer
handle participated in and delivered
this to the White House and or national
security adviser
Michael Flint now earlier this month
based on the New York Times reporting
Michael Cohen admitted this after the
entire Michael Flynn scandal exploded
Michael cook we've heard denials that
Michael Cohen was actually involved we
now know that Michael Flynn was forced
to resign etc etc everyone but the Trump
administration at this point Pat is
confirming the plan existed Michael
Cohen was involved and it was given
either directly or via White House proxy
to Michael Flynn once again another
aspect of the Trump Russia connections
that are initially dismissed by anybody
who can call it fake news and it ends up
being corroborated by multiple sources
and how telling is it that our D'Amico
is being investigated by his own
Ukrainian government and you know he's a
member of parliament there whereas us on
the other hand you'd have people who
weren't even part of the administration
at the time where the incoming members
of trumps administration and maybe
Michael Flynn is losing his job over
this but otherwise they're kind of left
off the hook legally speaking well
Michael Cohen has been claiming that he
never gave the plan to Flynn or
discussed it with anyone at the White
House that he's made now three or four
conflicting comments he wasn't involved
he was involved but he didn't give it to
Flynn he gave it to Flynn whatever the
White House says it has no record of
receiving such a document whatsoever
which I'm finding increasingly difficult
to believe
seit Felix aider are two men CO and the
New York Times all stand by their claims
that Michael Cohen gave the plan to
Flynn and by the way
wise Trump's personal lawyer who
presumably has nothing to do with this
administration even remotely involved in
this stuff so Cohen has changed his
story multiple times confirmed to the
New York Times initially that he had the
meeting and that he delivered the plan
to the White House to the what to the
New York Times then told The Washington
Post that he didn't deliver it didn't
even know what the plan was then he told
Business Insider that the meeting
happened and that Russia thinks the plan
would create world peace but that he
didn't give the plan to the White House
then last week NBC News asks Cohen did
you deliver the plan to the White House
and without officially admitting
anything Cohen said so what
what's wrong with that and then on
Friday Cohen told CNN that he had dinner
with our two men Co but that the topic
of Ukraine just didn't come up what I'm
counting like five different positions
on this from Michael Cohen right it's
kind of Exhibit A when you think about
the connections between Trump and Russia
or at least the Trump campaign the true
team in Russia because I mean this is
part of the story that they've kind of
had to admit to yeah I mean Trump firing
Flynn over Russian connections leads you
to believe that there's more things
there and it kind of gives it
credibility and by the way fun fact
speaking of credibility the Trump Russia
blackmail dossier claims that Cohen met
with a Russian representative in Prague
to discuss Russia's hacking of the DNC
another aspect that may be true although
again initially we supposedly Cohen
never went to Prague and I guess he
showed his passport to trump but who
really knows the news is fake but the
leaks are real that's the new phrase of
top of trumps that I'm going to be
repeating whenever we talk about this
game fly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low used price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
Gamefly offer.com slash TDPS the games
are shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDPS